er hat ärger mit der firma stage
entertainment die sind ja bekannt für
wirklich gigantisch tolle musicals und
herr schäfer sie sind krebspatient und
haben das problem dass sie jetzt ihr
geld nicht zurückbekommen wie geht sie
das mal persönlich doch es geht mir
eigentlich recht gut ich bin
zuversichtlich und positiv eingestellt
dass das durch das ganze überstehen kann
ich bin in guten händen habe ich sehr
gut der erste gefunden und das leben
geht weiter
bestellt wie bitte woran leiden sie
genau also melanom aosta krebs und
wasser als dekoration muss das ist ja
wirklich ein ganz schön hartes schicksal
toll dass sie da so offen drüber reden
und jetzt auch noch dazu der ärger mit
den musical karten da nehme ich mal ganz
kurz an kempkens dazu herr campions hier
haben wir wirklich sehr sehr viele
rückmeldungen von zuschauern die sagen
das kann doch nicht angehen da kann doch
stage entertainment nicht zumuten dass
ich jetzt praktisch durch die ganze
republik fahre und praktisch meine
gutscheine wieder einzulösen
wie ist die rechtliche lage da also die
ticket lösung sagte grundsätzlich dass
der veranstalter berechtigt ist eben ein
gutschein auszustellen der gültig ist
bis zum 31 12 2021 nur wenn er dann
nicht eingelöst wird gibt es geld zurück
aber es gibt eben auch die
härtefallklausel und die
härtefallklausel sagt eben das ist auch
im gesetz übrigens so verankert das ist
jetzt kein entgegenkommen des
veranstalters sondern das ist der
gesetzestext wenn es aufgrund der
persönlichen situation unzumutbar ist
bekomme ich jetzt sofort mein geld
zurück und diese fallen hier eines
schwerkranken kunden der einfach das
geld jetzt aus verschiedenen gründen
zurück haben will das ist natürlich ein
klassischer härtefall grund und da muss
sofort zurückgezahlt werden
herr schäfer sie ärgern sich da jetzt
wie ist so das verhalten wie empfinden
sie das verhalten von stage
entertainment ihnen gegenüber ich würde
mal sagen sehr miserabel ich finde ich
finde es eine schweinerei wie die firma
ihre kunden
das team schon mal so loos das
wochenlang pingpong gespielt wurde
zwischen mir hamburg travel und stage
entertainment jeder hat auch den anderen
geschoben und sagte ich bin nicht
ständig mails zu sehen wie unser weiter
schlussendlich habe ich dann in mitte
oder ende juli von stage entertainment
das erste mal was gehört in form von
zwei einem gutschein für das geld das
bezahlt haben
fast 600 euro es waren also nicht nur
karten für mich um eine vorauswahl auf
geraten für meine 76 jährige verhandelt
zu ihrem geburtstag und meine 55 jährige
cousine die beide in südbaden wohnen
eine in altersheim bei freiburg und die
anderen lehrer und mittlerweile ist
meine tante auch nicht mehr reisefähig
sie könnten wir nach europa kommen jetzt
wenn sie wollte ja das ist ziemlich
bitter als sie sagen sie sind vielleicht
auch demnächst nicht mehr reisefähig wie
gehen sie denn ins nächste jahr
ich freue mich sehr dass das nächste
jahren wir hoffen dass wir wieder weisen
können wir haben eine immer gerne
gereist meine frau nicht weiterreisen
gemacht wir waren auch lange lange jahre
im ausland in südafrika und in
australien daher auch der hautkrebs und
wir freuen uns darauf hoffentlich unser
tochter wiedersehen zu können die in
melbourne australien gibt was bringen
denn diese musicals ist das jetzt so
auch wirklich normalen eine möglichkeit
mehr richtig auszusteigen und mal
abzuschalten
ja und wir lieben die musik auch um von
diesen musicals gerade königlich eines
unter unserer favorisierten ja zum
beispiel auch phantom der oper oder cats
wenn man mehrmals schon dort und des
musicals geben uns einfach drei stunden
oder oder vier stunden wenn man alles
andere mit einem schönen abendessen
verbindet rasten schönen tag und
wirklich an nicht an diesem scheiß krebs
denken muss da stimmt und sie haben uns
auch gesagt sie wissen gar nicht ob sie
dann im nächsten jahr irgendwelche
gutscheine einlösen könnten wie sehen
sie das
ja das kann natürlich immer passieren
und mein arzt meinte auch beim krebs ist
man nicht sicher
wir wiederum und was dann ist wie in
welchem es etwas das kann da als auch
nicht garantieren
da gibt es auch keine keine richtwerte
sind halt einfach so eine krankheit mit
der muss man leben so langes bild und
sie würden doch trotzdem relativ
optimistisch
sie habe selbst natürlich mit stage
entertainment auch kontakt gehabt da
gibt man sich eher wortkarg und es gibt
allgemeine äußerungen das ist natürlich
ein sehr hohes aufkommen ist von
beschwerden und natürlich das thema
härtefallregelungen da habe ich auch
noch mal konkret danach gefragt da gab
es bislang keine antwort aber wir haben
darüber auch berichteten tatsächlich
haben wir sehr sehr großes feedback
bekommen von menschen die fühlen sich da
einfach ungerecht behandelt an kempkens
was kann man denn da überhaupt jetzt
noch machen
also ich würde jedem betroffenen
empfehlen hier mit dem veranstalter
kontakt aufzunehmen dann beruft man sich
auf diese härtefallklausel egal ob man
die karten noch hat oder ob man schon
was wahrscheinlich in den meisten fällen
so ist die gutscheine bekommen hat dann
wendet man sich schriftlich an den
veranstalter und sagt ich berufe mich
auf die härte klausel und dann muss man
die kurz begründen das war ja bei der
gesetzgebung ein bisschen umstritten
dass man jetzt auf einmal so etwas auch
äußern muss warum das nährte fall ist
aber das muss man schon tun man muss das
etwas begründen
dann setzt man eine zahlungsfrist ich
fordere sie auf innerhalb von zehn tagen
zu zahlen dann gibt man das konto an
und wenn dann nicht nach zehn tagen
gezahlt ist dann geraten die in verzug
die veranstalter und dann kann man
tatsächlich auch in beiden verfahren
einleiten
dass der eine fall tatsächlich krankheit
ist natürlich sicherlich auch ein grund
für eine härtefallregelung aber wie ist
das wenn ich zum beispiel reisen muss
und wenn wir haben ja gehört das geht ja
wirklich um relativ viel geld hotel
bahnfahrt ab wann ergreift denn für mich
wenn ich jetzt jetzt keine
gesundheitlichen probleme habe ab wann
geht denn dann für mich die
härtefallregelung also die
härtefallregelung sowie die
bundesregierung sich das vorgestellt hat
gilt auf jeden fall wenn man
beispielsweise in einem urlaub etwas
besuchen wollte und jetzt dieser urlaub
eben abgesagt es oder eben verschoben
ist und man sozusagen für ein neues
konzert auch wieder einen urlaub buchen
müsste das ist sicherlich ein härtefall
sicherlich auch ein härtefall ist
beispielsweise wenn man den finanziellen
schwierigkeiten ist in kurzarbeit und
dergleichen und ein dritter fall hätte
alles mit sicherheit auch die situation
dass man eigentlich erst am eigenen ort
beispielsweise ein konzert besuchen
sollte jetzt ist dieses konzert aber
abgesagt und das nachholkonzert oder ein
ersatzkonzept ist in einer ganz anderen
stadt das heißt ich hatte ursprünglich
ein konzert für meine eigene stadt
gekauft und soll jetzt auf einmal eine
längere anfahrt in kauf nehmen das ist
sicherlich auch ein härtefall also geld
zurück ein gutschein
herr schäfer sie sind da sehr sehr sauer
was würden sie jetzt stage entertainment
sagen ich würde an ihre menschlichkeit
appellieren und eben die zeit zumindest
diese härtefälle finanziell abdecken
und nicht nur das geld überweisen
sondern als wieder gut machen würde
schon fassaden trotzdem die gutscheine
gelten lassen so dass man eventuell
trotzdem noch den gutschein in anspruch
nehmen kann also tatsächlich auch noch
mein appell live stage entertainment
manager wir sehen hier wirklich einen
ganz ganz bitteren fall
und da geht mir wirklich das herz auf
und ich denke mir mal bei solchen
härtefällen sollen sie eigentlich sofort
reagieren und die leute auch nicht
weiter abspeisen